and i did like to see that actually sam
shanklin
was uh sitting there he doesn't have to
play the first round today's time he's
gonna get those three points walk over
win against rajabov but he was sitting
there so 15 players getting ready for
the final day of preliminaries seven of
them will uh
join rajabov in leaving the tournament
and eight will get ready for the quarter
finals levon aronian is uh currently in
the danger zone together with wei so do
you fully expect david both players to
go for a win in this game
i would think so although it depends how
much of an eye level neronian has on the
standings he could just look at this
game and think okay way ye is chasing me
let's just play it safe let's make sure
he doesn't win uh he doesn't leapfrog me
and then the last two games his fate is
still in his own hands but
yeah it's really tricky strategy levon
is not the type of player to play for a
draw in general and
he has not gone for a drawing variation
he's gone to something he's played a few
times already in this tournament a type
of anti-sicilian where he's just closing
the position not allowing any early pawn
breaks not really allowing any early
exchanges and
what do you guys think of this opening
choice he's played it a few times with
mick's success level on earlier he lost
to eric geisie with this opening
yeah i mean
when you play this type of opening with
the white pieces you're not really
saying to your opponent i'm going to try
to get a big advantage win quickly
what you are saying is okay i just want
to take the game into my kind of
battlefield i know the position might be
equal i know the computer probably
doesn't even agree with the way i'm
playing but i don't care i want to get a
position that i like a structure i like
and the structure is basically your
pawns the skeleton of your position and
he can decide where they go but
it must be okay for black as well i mean
black is totally fine uh there's no
danger at this moment in time yeah i've
noticed when studying these types of
opening positions myself computers often
even slightly prefer black
that's what kind of drives white players
away from uh choosing openings like this
nowadays you turn on the computer so you
see oh it might say plus 0.5 for black
and it's only move eight let's not even
investigate further but uh of course
levon as you said he understands the
skeleton of the position he understands
the plans where the pieces will go he
understands what he wants to do quite
deep into the middle game and
where he could have predicted this
opening because levon has been playing
it several times already this tournament
but he is the first one to think
where he may be surprised maybe just
he analyzed with the computer up to this
point he saw oh black's doing well he
didn't look any further but
black does need a plan which side of the
board is black going to play on maybe in
the center maybe on the queen side
uh he needs to start pushing some pawns
black at some point
but how to do that
yeah ivanka has this position been
played before it has been played before
uh many times actually i say many but
that's probably about uh 30 times which
isn't that much
i'm a big fan of this particular system
that lavon is playing primarily because
it fits in with the type of chess that i
was playing when i was younger
it was always you know just develop the
pieces threaten to set up a big pawn
center in the middle of the board and
then sit on the space and enjoy the
freedom that your pieces give you and i
i like this time chess yes as uh simon
and david have mentioned that the
computer is not a big fan but in reality
there are humans playing and there's
always the opportunity to go wrong yeah
it's what we call a system right it's
not necessarily an opening where you
have to memorize lots of forcing
variations it's a system where you know
where you'll put your pawns you know
where you'll put your pieces you know
what your plan is next
we talk about the london system it's
quite generic there's an outline you
know in advance what you're going to do
and uh that's what he's going for here
obviously maneuver is quite typical yeah
i'd say this is one of the best ways to
learn david for a lot of players i mean
you know even if you're much lower rated
doing systems i think is such a better
way to learn about chess i mean a lot of
people you know memorizing lines using
chess ball the great chess ball to do
that is is is a good thing to do but
you've got to know the ideas behind the
moves you're memorizing it's like a
parrot you know a parrot you know
memorizes words but it probably doesn't
know the meaning of the words um so
you've got to know the meaning of the
moves you're playing and uh with these
kind of positions i mean this is exactly
what aronia is doing you saw that night
move he knows that knight's going to the
king side he's going to move his pawns
forwards
and this i think gets you to understand
chess a bit better right when you're
playing systems so highly recommended
way to play
and i think that's why one of the
reasons why the london system is so
popular
because you just have to work out your
plans yeah as simon says yep the knight
is coming forward at some point and then
the pawn stepping forward and he's done
this uh at least three times i think
already this tournament do we know where
the the name comes from london system
obviously it must be from london yeah
this is this is not the london system
here the london system is very popular
system probably the most popular and
that came about from the
1922
tournament in london and i hope i'm not
making this up i know everyone that one
believes
which everyone knows i think it was
actually a famous chess tournament in
london
in 1922 but you know i could be making
out 100 years ago
yeah so simon explain uh if we just go
back temporarily the the london system
would start with this pawn pushing
forward uh why it's night coming out and
no matter what black does the white
bishop coming out and maybe we can
explain why this is a system
yeah it's a system because
i guess you can just break it down into
mini plans so
all your pieces is white if you just
look at it from a white point of view
you know where every single piece is
going to go and you know why they're
going there and you know where your
king's going to go you know why you have
to adapt a little bit to what your
opponent plays but you don't really need
to memorize individual moves you just
know i put my piece here because it's
doing this job
and then you get into the middle game
in a nice sort of easy way i guess
that's that's why it's so popular right
i mean for players don't have time to
memorize uh you know beginners
lots of different moves so exactly and
he's basically doing the same as the
london system but just on the opposite
flank so if you look at white set up
here he's just a mirror image so here
he's brought his knight out and also
brought his bishop out
so it's very similar he knows that on
the next few moves his bishop's going to
drop back he knows he's going to push
his pawns to these two squares no matter
what black does he knows he's going to
for example later on white uh castled
and he knows he's going to bring his
knight back to this square and reroute
it as he's just done in the game and uh
as we see
black has kicked back white's bishop but
white bishop wants to go here anyway
that's part of the system part of the
plan
the bishop on this square actually
supports your central pawn for later it
also indirectly later potentially will
attack along this diagonal towards the
black king first as well you push this
pawn forward and this opening looks
identical now to actually a spanish
opening which we get from a completely
different first move for black but using
the pattern recognition there using the
information he has about where to put
his pieces bringing his bishop out now
at some point pushing a pawn forward in
the center it's just automatic and
that's why irony still has nearly 16
minutes on his clock so he moved that
bishop three times but that was just
because he wanted it to go to that exact
square yeah it's partly necessity
because it the bishop always gets kicked
around but he developed it and it's
actually on a good diagonal the two
bishops often bishops together like this
they have potential and look at this the
position's about to open up and if it
does open up then this bishop will be
well placed if the center disappears it
will be on a great diagonal
so um again it's just all about the
systems memorizing two or three
different patterns and then choosing the
order with which uh you play them and as
simon says great for when you're
starting out chess because it cuts out
all the nonsense of
kind of knuckling down and memorizing
sharp long variations which actually
doesn't improve the understanding
yeah yeah and
yeah i was also going to assure you
simon that uh you can breathe a sigh of
relief i did quickly check up how the
london system got its name and it was
from a tournament in 1922. nice memory
good
good call there haven't ruined my brain
quite
genuinely thought you were trolling us
i wasn't sure either i was kind of like
yeah 1922 london
yeah so
yeah just pick a random year oh
something ending in 2010
impressive knowledge uh certainly it's
impressive and uh meanwhile a set of
boards so the pawns have left the board
and using walls yeah no boards i said
boards i got it
an interesting game they got some balls
[Laughter]
have left the board and now there's a
new added element to the position i mean
who is going to utilize that now open
line on the c file and uh
is white threatening to step the pawn
forward the the d pawn one square
forward grab some space
and
all sorts of questions that wei yi now
has to contemplate also white has
actually sacrificed a pawn we should
mention for example if black captures in
the center right now with a knight or
with his pawn then white will
temporarily at least be a pawn down you
cannot okay he has captured with the
pawn but you cannot go and grab this
pawn back yet because then the black
queen would swoop down and win the white
bishop uh white's bishop needs to be
protected by its queen for example queen
takes pawn queen takes bishop would
immediately lose for white and just like
in the game it's very similar after pawn
takes pawn white cannot now go and
capture it with his knight
same problem after a trade the black
queen comes and wins a bishop so
how do we think level neronian is going
to win back the pawn he sacrificed the
pawn is very weak it shouldn't last for
too long it's also doubled right now so
it's not a massive concern but
is there something immediate the
computer really likes white's position
suddenly
i was i was going to suggest forget
about the pawn for the time being and
just develop the pieces
and uh yeah to ask questions bishop has
come out that sounds good lining up
against the queen
maybe threatening to explode the uh the
position even more i mean another move
that i was also thinking you know those
rhymes just uh
keep coming to me to mind and i'm just
thinking a knight on f5 will thrive
maybe
put a piece there later a knight might
land here
maybe if if the black bishop goes away
if black loses control over that square
and knight would love to jump in uh also
the black queen has put herself
willingly where he he put his queen on
this square to line up that trick
against the white bishop but the queen
might regret sitting on the square now
because the white rook is just going to
swing across and
all the pawns have disappeared on this
uh open file the black queen will need
to move again very shortly
so yeah it looks uh pretty nice for
white the black bishop meanwhile coming
out
and is it time to bring the rook across
is it time as ivanka mentions to maybe
jump in with one of the two white
knights they could both jump towards the
black king right now
you could maybe push this ball forward
in the center to open up the diagonal we
mentioned this bishop has got potential
so much choice for levon aronian
yeah i mean i i guess black's you know
quite comfortable as well though i mean
uh pretty solid
i think this last move was maybe
important the way he played because
white was getting ready for ideal sort
of situation with the white rook which
you can play now but i don't know if it
works okay the knights jumped in and
this is trying to get the bishop pair um
but yeah i don't like that night being
there i really want to take that but
then you open up the other rook so
looking a little bit more comfortable
for white i guess
trade here as you mentioned opens up
this rook i'm not a huge fan i must say
of that night jump at all for white i've
seen it go wrong too many times where
this pawn actually just gets in the way
of your attack you want this pawn gone
in order to free up your bishop but
level knows his stuff i'm gonna trust
him now and uh yeah this night jump
at least it's gonna yield white the
bishop a lot of pressure now on black's
position with this knight
levon playing very fast though he's been
doing that uh
uh the whole tournament hasn't he yeah
maybe a little bit too fast it was a
recipe for success last season on the
tour quite often uh levon had some good
results playing fast especially when he
was playing magnus carlson he managed to
win a really important match and that
was because he was faster than magnus he
was more confident than magnus but yeah
this tournament it hasn't served him too
well i guess if you're playing fast
relying on instinct it depends on form
if your instincts are sharp if you're
super fresh
then playing fast makes a lot of sense
but if you're not calculating as quickly
as normal if you're slightly out of form
then playing fast
um yep you might make an odd blunder
here or there we've seen that from levon
aroni in this tournament yeah this uh
thing about instinct and magnus has
talked a lot about it like oh my my
instinct is not working or my instinct
is very sharp
can you
can you train your instinct can you make
sure that this is you know for a world
championship match or a big tournament i
need my instinct to be on on point can
you sort of time it like give you know
an an athlete in the olympics will you
know
time their top form for the olympics
is it possible as a chess player of
question that's an interesting question
because somehow i've i mean i'll just
kind of have to answer the question
personally i mean i've always treated
this kind of
issue of form and instinct as being
something almost of a divine nature you
know somehow it's part of luck or
something um the way that i train i mean
especially now that i'm playing in the
olympiad is i will be training on
calculation and solving as many
positions and problems as i can in order
to develop that instinct so if i see a
similar pattern there is some part of my
mind working on a subconscious level
operating and just making sure that my
hand is ready to play the correct move
yeah
what do you think david yeah can you
time it
i think you can in a way for example if
i know that the big goal um if
for example you mentioned those athletes
timing it for the olympics if the big
goal is a certain time format or a
certain race or a certain game uh if for
example i'm aiming for this tournament
where it's 15 minutes it's online i
would just be playing as much as i can
maybe some of my practice would be over
the board chess but the big target the
kind of the bulk of my work would be
practicing this time limit against
similar strength opponents
and uh
usually
that tends to help i mean level neronian
for example he's been playing quite a
lot recently but very little online and
very little rapid chance he's been
playing different time formats and i
think it's just taking him time to get
back in the zone where his instincts are
on point for the 15 minute time control
yeah maybe his instincts would be great
in blitz time controls or longer time
controls but at the moment his instincts
are just uh maybe slightly rustier um
and this time format and it's same for
athletes they might be
running loads they might be just to
practice but then for the 800 meters
they haven't done that exact
amount for a while so
um yeah there are ways like ivanka says
doing puzzles playing blitz chess making
sure the speed is there the sharpness is
there but it's different for everyone
and uh
i think levon maybe hasn't been
prioritizing the online format so much
lately now he's back in the zone and
maybe by day five of this tournament if
he's qualified for the knockouts maybe
he'll be
fully fresh again his instincts firing
on all cylinders very interesting now we
do have a few moves how are these
instincts working in this game yeah
interesting developments in the game
they have we did see that white knight
on f5
it was just too strong the knight and f5
should not be allowed to survive and it
was exchanged off
and uh now yeah after this kind of funny
porn move by wei yi on the left side of
the board white now has these doubled
pawns but white has some holes in the
position and levon aronian the move i'm
really surprised by is this last one
offering up the bishop pair he's
allowing an exchange now i thought the
bishop power was maybe white's
kind of pride and joy in this position
what do you guys think
it's a bit of an odd move but uh when i
was looking at the position i couldn't
find a great home for the dark square
bishop and perhaps lavon just also
couldn't see a solution there and
decides to trade it off but i mean
i mean the first move you've got to
calculate is what happens if uh black
simply cap swaps off those bishops yeah
and uh mike takes the bishop
and i'm assuming that a kickback will
happen because you can't let the white
knight sit there on g5 square
menacing some of your squares around the
black king
that is a dangerous idea and that dave
is highlighting but uh okay so if the
knight is kicked back is lavon's idea
just to go all in
yeah that's how
i was thinking
black knight at least is ready to drop
back if it needs to to protect its king
black's king it's hard to kind of
loosen it up it's hard to open up any
lines towards it
maybe the white knight will just step
back
and it looks a bit sad but maybe it'll
step back trying to
conquer this pawn at some point
maybe the idea is just to use this
bishop at some point and line it up
against the black knights or maybe on
this diagonal later
it doesn't look too convincing at all to
me i don't see
any tricks here for white
yeah it's a kind of a complicated
position as well because
you see it's it's pretty open and you
kind of have to take it on a move by
move basis but at the final position
you've got it seems like black is doing
okay yeah black can take this pawn maybe
even uh go back up uh pawn up
black's knight has this great square
potentially an outpost it can start
annoying the white pieces from
i mean i'm not saying white's worse but
it's a bit strange what's been happening
and
if i were ye i would just love to trade
this bishop off immediately just
release any pressure okay he ignores
that tension and he takes this pawn
first of all but this feels a bit loose
i i don't see any immediate tactics but
this rook is undefended
oh bar reacts just feels loose this rook
is undefended
this night is a bit loose this knight is
undefended
hmm
what can white try now
yeah um maybe maybe something like just
bishop b freya is is pretty sensible
um to to tie that rook off and black's
knight in the center is very strong
we mentioned white's bishop is is not
doing a great job
um so possibly moving there is getting a
better option i mean this looks very
good um the computer however says that
white has three good moves one gives
quite a significant advantage and that
is just the simple bishop takes bishop
okay that's yeah slightly surprising
yeah but the second move is really
surprising right i mean uh wow that's uh
it's kind of moved that he he won't play
that move let's have a bet
we haven't had a bet rook takes bishop
would that be on your radar no and i bet
he doesn't play it anyone want to take
me on why is it a strange move i can
obviously see the queen
on that line giving up a rook for a
bishop either of the knights can take
you now so you actually lose
material and yeah he doesn't play it he
plays your move simon this i mean maybe
there's a follow-up maybe you can push
your pawn forward and go on an attack
against the black king but i think that
was just too difficult for any human
it's a big material investment a rook
for a bishop as well
so we can't blame levon aronian for
missing that one and not sacrificing
instead he plays a more human type of
move and um yeah keeper may be keeping
this one in his pocket for later the
third move that the computer suggested
here actually i thought maybe you would
have liked simon just pushing harry the
each pawn up one square to support this
bishop but nope the white bishop
attacked the knight and now we finally
do see this exchange of dark squared
bishops
and some pressure now against the black
position this knight was undefended it's
hit it has to retreat
and even more pressure being added the
momentum is picking up in white's favor
actually threat after threat
this is a pin
yeah how does he break the pin he has to
move the black queen surely and we under
five minutes on the clock but there's
some uncomfortable pressure on the f7
pawn as well yeah it really reminds me
of the time when i was playing a game
like and it was almost very similar to
this i had the bishop and the knight
lined up on the f7 pawn when a grand
master walks past me
and says to me you've got a lot of
pressure on that pawn and i was like
thank you
yeah during a game i was so annoyed
because if someone had heard this i mean
it was the most obvious thing in the
world if someone had heard this they
would have been they could have said you
cheated yeah but i mean i'm just i'm
just thinking the weirdest thing that
someone let's say a grandmaster has done
during a game
uh i think i can probably beat it and
you could probably try to guess the
grand master if you want to but
this is actually a bit weird um
grandmaster licks my ear once
yeah i'm not joking in the forum cl
so
why
because he's really weird and i mean
nowadays he could get arrested for that
right yeah for licking yeah and it was
like what are you doing yeah literally
like yeah it was weird so he just walked
around like the boys walked around and
it's like
yeah it's very strange inspired by mike
tyson maybe it didn't bite you know i
think maybe i preferred it if he bit in
my ear i don't know licking me it was
weird but i
don't know
i think i can guess you that yeah yeah i
was going to say later you'll ask later
okay yeah can you beat that david i
can't beat that sign nobody's ever
licked uh that was nice
very strange yeah how did you react i
just i was just very weird right i mean
i was just like well literally what are
you doing
and it was like yeah it was it wasn't
even your opponent right it was just and
i mean that would be
that would be even weird
what did your opponent do then i think
he was just thinking i mean like this
guy was just walking around and he was
like you know just sort of yeah you get
this like
weird feeling and it's like
and it's literally in the middle of the
tournament because you know there's like
200 people in the hall and it's like
would you what'd you do
what would you what'd you do when that
happens did you you know do you
punch him or do you should you
shout him or did you just get on with
the game it's very confusing were you
able to concentrate again afterwards i'm
well i mean yeah it took me a while
right to get back into it because you're
like just confused yeah more than
anything so yeah that anyway that that
was that was weird i hope that never
happens to any viewers uh at home
no ever throughout their chess careers
would you you wouldn't like that would
you like uh you know
i think i would go for your yeah i think
that would be terrible i think nowadays
you probably should just call the
arbiter right and just say this guy i
mean it's quite a weird thing to say uh
excuse me arbiter that guy's just licked
my ear
i think i would call the police
could it be a new form of chest though
everything is allowed to pull your
opponent's off no no no no no no
that's uh
it's like a bad idea and
okay
well where you was feeling that the
pressure was a little bit uncomfortable
on the f7 pawn and he pushes his d pawn
forward and uh whilst levon aronian is
thinking well
it's the final day of preliminaries half
the field are going to leave the
competition so it's going to be a
dramatic day and as always we love it
when you at home are part of the fun
sending us your selfies sending us your
comments and of course showing us where
you're watching from how you're watching
with and you can do that by tweeting us
using the hashtag chesschamps and uh to
kick us all off i'd like to share with
you a little chess themed photo from
abhishek who's asking us
how do we like his chess tattoo of the
mighty king that's so we love it uh we
were talking about tattoos the other day
you're talking about what kind of
chestertou's one should get yeah well
david i'm on the lookout for good
designs so if any viewers do have any
ideas maybe this one from abhishek but
uh yeah i'm looking out for some uh
ink ideas let's see it's very cool david
a chest does it have to be a chess
tattoo or are you open to anything i'm
open-minded but chess would be a bonus
that's great yeah you get a grandmaster
looking
here
definitely won't get an image of that
no no
no no no maybe it could be like your
score sheet from the game when you
officially became grand master oh yeah
that game was rather boring and it's
probably really long
it's probably like all the way down his
leg
around the back it was only 200 moves
[Laughter]
you know
i was listening to a podcast this
morning about proust
uh apparently you probably know him
philosopher you know he wrote these
really long books and the whole podcast
was saying that you should read boost
because it slows you down i'm thinking
suddenly that we should all play through
david's games because it would slow us
down yeah you know we are now in the
business of everything being fast five
minutes ba-boom
on to the next and instead
maybe it will just make you want to be
faster because it's like oh do we have
to keep going
one of the things i think we want to
slow down with my youtube channel quite
a lot people say i i watch it to go to
sleep
i'll reach out how to take that side do
i have that soothing voice no i don't
think so but maybe you know to sort of
you know just get in the right zone
because sort of
asmr right that would be really good
yeah yeah i have sent several arbiters
to sleep during my games uh
several and i've sent a couple of
opponents to sleep during this
great idea of a podcast they david's
long grinds
it started with the e4
136 g3
there you go this is
listening to your voice just before they
go to bed
yeah does that make sense the way to pop
the right chest yeah and this is the the
s what's the name sm asmr it's very
popular right
it's huge on youtube and podcasts and
stuff i've seen lots of chess videos
kind of been saying accidentally asmr
yeah yeah because the channel wasn't
there asmr
chess um this chess one which is very
popular i know the guy runs it but he's
secret oh guys so he's not supposed to
mention his name
so yeah
popularity googling that one later yeah
meanwhile after a pretty long think for
iranian standards at least he dropped
back the white knight putting some
pressure on black's pawns in the center
and the black queen moved so
let's just recap white is actually
temporarily a pawn down right now we
haven't been talking about that too much
because the
two center pawns for black those double
d pawns they're both going to be very
weak one of them might drop off and
meanwhile irony is going for it he's
pushed his pawn forward he's trying to
launch a pawn storm towards the black
king but weakening the white king as
well in the process and the computer
really hates that last move maybe
because the white king is actually the
week of the two right now
and black's knight jumps in
it looks like it's turning in black's
favor suddenly totally does i have to
say i visibly recoiled when i saw that
porn move come on the board it was so
surprising i did not expect it at all
and uh you know
take a look at levon aronian's pieces
they are not primed for
a kingside attack they are primed for
action in the middle that's where he
should be focusing his efforts on and
white's king looking rather shaky at the
minute i don't like what's happened yeah
it looks really inconsistent what he's
just done his last two moves maybe if we
uh go to recap because
we were discussing okay these two
doubled pawns they're targets maybe
there's some way to slowly build up some
pressure against them maybe move the
white queen coordinate the white rooks
but uh throwing this pawn forward i
understand the idea he wants to kick
away this knight and it looks like this
knight is defending this central pawn
but after the black knight wanted to
jump into the center anyway
maybe aronian just underestimated the
fact that bishop takes pawn is not
possible it looks like white's regained
the pawn
forking for two knights a double attack
there but uh this knight jump is just
terminal this night jump hits the queen
and hits the bishop and wins material so
um levon aronian instead had to retreat
his knight but this is where the
inconsistency is pushing upon opening up
your king and then retreating instead of
going on the
attack going forward stepping back
and now also once the knight disappears
maybe black has better maybe black's
knight should actually jump into this
square that looks very tempting but even
if the knights disappear for example the
white king is always going to be open
later in the game
so
yeah it just feels like a step in the
wrong direction
and that being said what is where you
going to play he does keep the knights
on the board he plays this knight in
and it's queen moves
i would love to somehow improve this
black knight now you can't quite jump
into the center yet the square's covered
by the white rook but if you could
somehow jump into this square
this is kind of the dream square for the
black knight maybe you can go the other
way
maybe you can jump this way putting some
pressure on the white bishop and then
jumping into this square which is nicely
supported by these two pawns
just all looks wrong for white
it does and
does black have to worry about the pawn
that's up for grabs in the middle of the
board
uh yeah maybe this bishop can take a
pawn there's some pressure here on this
on the third rank but maybe no way for
black to capitalize on that at the
moment so instead
of that night jump if we go back uh the
bishop attacking the spawn where he
decides to jump into this square also
quite uh convincing
attacking this lone ranger right now the
white a pawn but also defending black's
pawn in the center
those two black knights they're starting
to take over their sons who can really
control everything right now this white
rook is
not such a happy piece
no and uh i really like this uh night
move as well because it clears the third
row for the queen look at the queen you
know she's on that goldilocks line you
know she can switch the left switch to
the right
and uh yeah doing great defensive and
offensive work
yeah if if wei e beats levon aronian now
erroneous chances
they're going to take a massive hit yeah
it's his direct rival he's going to be
overtaken where he's guaranteed another
three points
uh from that rajabov clash that's true
i mean it's very tricky position to play
as well isn't it i mean for white
because you can't play it safe anymore
they can't and you know black can just
take pawns and catch pawns i mean i was
trying to try to create some counter
play i think in situations like this
where things are going pretty wrong
you know you you've got to okay a couple
of moves have been played but you got to
try to create some counter play so i
really wanted to open up black's king
but as you say black's queen doing a
great job of defending all that and i
just want to mention a massive result
juwen jun has already after 30 minutes
won her game against hans niem on the
tilt continues for niman but three
points for ju wen jun that takes her
back in contention for qualification she
could be the first female player to make
it to the knockout stage in the military
champions chess store that would be
amazing i think everyone can agree on
that
three points for her takes her to 15
points currently
in ninth place and she will face off
against anish giri in the next round
exciting stuff that's very exciting
because yesterday everything went wrong
for her and i have to say i played
through her games and a lot of it wasn't
her fault you know she lost on time in a
completely drawn position level position
i should say against duda maybe that
could have been internet troubles
because sometimes you have like she was
disconnected yeah and then she
disconnected later on as well
and so she lost two games right against
mama jaroff yeah and mama jaffe it was
totally level and you know one of those
days
you really feel frustrated you're just
like come on this is you know this has
been her tournament she's been shining
throughout and now this happens on a
critical day so it's fantastic to see
her do well against neiman and when it
comes to neiman sorry simon uh i i was
reminded of i was watching doctor
strange for all of like 10 minutes after
the show
and uh there's a scene right where he
tries to do some magic or whatever he
does he does and the lady goes to him
drop the ego and the power will rise or
something
and i was like oh maybe this is like the
the thing with chess players need to do
just like drop the ego when you lose
drop the ego drop those negative stories
you tell yourself and just let it all
flow
yeah there you go me taking inspiration
from marvel i know i know it's a little
bit sadistic i may be a little bit cruel
but if hans does lose all his free games
kya can you interview him
straight away
the crowd wants it
right now you will be a little bit angry
he said yesterday i don't understand why
you want to interview me
now but of course we did it's important
to talk to uh the ones who's struggling
as well and then this one is lavon still
struggling uh it's unclear suddenly he's
actually two pawns down level neronian
black has three pawns now on the left
half of the board
those
d pawns as well
still surviving but a bit weak it's just
about whether levon can firstly trap
that black knight that black knight has
no retreat squares anymore it got greedy
grabbed a pawn but it has nowhere safe
to run
but also can lev on while that black
knight tries to extricate itself tries
to find an escape route can everyone
just pick up all of black's pawns the
pawns on the d-file that black b-pawn
maybe as well
lots of questions suddenly for you to
answer and only one minute on the clock
to find those solutions it's not easy
anymore i do feel way complicated the
matter a bit too much he could have done
something very similar but in a more
risk-free way
suddenly levons found this tricky queen
retreat which i don't think was on way
east radar and
it's knights really yeah
out of the game
i'm thinking i mean
it's a good question
black queen maybe yeah i mean knights on
the rim just typical
typical problem here the black scot and
it was actually what g wen jun did wrong
as well i think in the game we we
covered yesterday due when jun moved the
night out of the you know to to the side
of the board
and that that made her lose the game
against dominguez it's the night stable
simon the knight is completely trapped
by the queen look at the queen it
controls this kind of uh portion of the
board and that's all of the squares that
the black knight wants to use uh so okay
the black queen has had to try and
challenge
um its rival over here a queen trade i
think would get levon out of any danger
he could trade off the queens then trade
off the knight and then start grabbing
some pawns back he can start grabbing
this pawn and this should fizzle out
towards a draw um all the pawns are
disappearing it's just rooks on the
board oh i was going to say maybe if he
was feeling more ambitious he could keep
the queens on but he has taken them off
and after
trading the queens instead of taking the
knight actually he's just created this
pin
so uh he is still playing ambitious
leader on auronian trying to pin uh the
knight to the rook behind it and the
problem for black is you can't currently
defend your knight with your other rook
because after a couple of trades here
after everything disappears from the
board there is a nasty checkmate
and uh black's king has no breathing
space but i think the trick is after
he's defended his knight if everything
does disappear then at the very end he
does have this pawn push to
at least keep this white rook honest for
now
white's rook now cannot kind of maintain
this checkmating idea so when it moves
then black will capture the white bishop
and black still has a lot of pawns black
still has these three
and uh yeah maybe 11 irony and missed
this uh missed this last move
missed this pawn push it's very
important paul bush yeah it's uh
important to have a key in tactical
well it's a keen sense of tactics
because that i'd missed that as well i
thought it wasn't possible to play that
move
just uh maybe in the current position i
was going to say it's the same idea
bishop takes pawn looks like it's a
double attack hitting this rook still
with an eye on the knight but the black
pawn again pushes forward
as you mentioned uh ivanka just
keenly spotting way that he can use
tactics to survive here
is it gonna get simplified now after the
rook just slides
one square to the left
you have to keep an eye on the pawn i
think and luckily white's always got the
option of swapping the knight swapping
some things off yeah so is this
getting getting liquidated now maybe
guess the black rooks will move maybe
uh from the attack or this move yeah
this move is possible now i was uh
reluctant to do any calculation here but
the calculation is actually quite simple
after a rook trade white takes this pawn
now this game is heading towards a draw
uh most likely both sides have four
pawns white's four pawns are not
actually so impressive because these are
doubled so white's four is basically the
same as black's three
black does have this one kind of trump
card to be pawn but it's not too
impressive after a check
and
yeah you can trade off this bishop you
can leave it on either way it should be
a draw personally i would just take it
off and
avoid any risk but okay he traits the
rooks that's actually very clever
and uh a rook end game white has to
start racing the king over to stop this
pawn before it's too late but i think
white should be in time it should still
be a draw
even with the clock situation could
levon look at the way's time and see
that he only has
about a minute to go is there
anything he can
sort of impose some problems
i don't think so there have just been
too many exchanges
too many pieces have left the board and
especially
the way ye calculates uh i keep saying
the way
but uh yeah the chinese school of chess
as well they're so good at calculating
two or three move tricks two or three
move sequences they can calculate it in
milliseconds
uh so in this type of position there
will never be long long tactics it's
because there's so few pieces on the
board it's just about confirming this
two three move sequence is fine for me i
can play it and uh with one minute on
the clock that should be enough now
now flagging has been a theme lately in
chess is it kromnic who's been very
critical of players who who flag which
basically means you you're
not winning on the board but you win on
the clock play for the clock yeah
we don't see that uh maybe in rapid
chess as much no but in thai breaks we
could see it maybe
potentially yeah especially in uh
armageddon i guess that is the nature of
the game i mean he had some had a great
choice of words he called flagging moral
degree degradation especially because
you know he was being flagged in like
lost position well he was winning and
his opponent was losing yeah or in
completely drawn positions and you know
it all happened at once and it was his
first time playing a tournament like
this and he's like never ever again yeah
but it sounds like a bad loser
i mean you're playing chess you know the
clock is part of the game right um i
have to admit i do moan a lot whenever i
get flagged i'm the same i'm like how
dare you do that but you know it is just
like it's part of the game right if you
live too slow you lose you know you've
got to move quicker um so i mean and
it's an exciting part of the game i'm
actually
quite against increment in general i
wish
i wish there was no increment i think it
would be much more exciting because
you'd see many more games ending on time
yeah and you see many more shootouts as
you can say so i i would love to bring
that back i don't know if david would
maybe uh i don't know dave david retire
immediately david lives on the increment
i mean often but there would be no more
200 move games
that's true actually you could have the
increment kick in i mean i kind of like
this idea that up to a certain amount of
moves there's no increment but once you
pass say like move 45 or 40 or something
then like a very slight increment kicks
in of like one second or so
and uh i know a lot of the top players
in the world at least they have your
opinion there simon
um i've spoken to a few of them and they
want to get rid of increment they say
why did it still exist yeah chess should
be an adrenaline sport it's quite funny
because i posted this on on twitter and
um you had all the artists started
coming in and they were like oh we did
our surveys and people prefer it this
way because it's a lot harder for the
art of going back to your artists again
it's a lot harder for the arbiters if
there is uh no extra time added on
they've got an extra extra job to do but
i i think in some tournaments it would
just be more exciting to have that
aspect maybe in the chess
i don't know if the standard might go
down a bit but okay you sacrifice that
for for excitement well we always love
it in armageddon right where we don't
have increment it's always a lot of fun
yeah exactly and this game meanwhile
might be heading towards a draw the
players have repeated the position once
uh aronian actually gave up a pawn
temporarily just to ruin black's pawn
structure so black has the doubled f
pawns now but the problem for wei yi
despite being a pawn up is that the
knight is actually inferior to the
bishop while pawns exist on both sides
of the board the knight is not on a good
circuit as uh either so
it doesn't have any kind of great
squares to go to
if we want to keep this battle alive the
black knight is going to have to go to
the edge of the board potentially but uh
no easy way back from there either so i
think wei yi will just give a nice check
as he did a couple of moves ago repeat
the position and this game should be a
draw i said earlier the level of rooney
and he lost control but actually he
fought back quite well after that and
okay no draw yet
he keeps the game alive where he
brave with only only 40 seconds on the
clock
and uh okay black's knight is at least
anchored
and white pushes forward
but
i i i can
i don't think wei yi is really trying
hard
to win i think he's just simply
prolonging the game and just seeing
whether levon just makes an error
somehow because
there's no way for black to activate the
king
and the knight is just dancing around by
itself
doing
i can't see it what it's doing
and uh
i i think oh well okay
again the way 10c the cat and mouse game
continues
yeah yeah
the wait and see
i have to say any puns i make are just
purely accessible
i i would like to see way versus way
versus so there could be a lot of puns
there so
wait okay
in the future that's so the way to go
yes
exactly
well we do uh we do have some
interesting results so jeffrey shong he
has won his game against shakira and
mohammed yab and that means shakuryad is
stuck on 18 points anish geary he uh
played a draw against sergeant erica's
that means he is on 18 points and with a
draw in this game well of an ironian he
will be on 18 points so three of the big
favorites in sixth to eighth place with
18 points and three points behind them
will be juwen jun weiyi will have
16 points and he will definitely gain
three points in the next game a walk
over win for him against him rajab of
taking him to 19. so i think levon and
anish and shakhriyad they must be
feeling the pressure yeah definitely
yeah i guess in levon's favor there is
the tiebreak where
we talk about a number of decisive games
he's lost a few but he's also won a lot
yeah so um if he ends up putting the
same score for example as wei yi his
games have been more uh maybe fighting
according to the result at least so that
would be one solace for him but
yeah i mean none of these players have
their fate in their own hands at the
moment they're just
hoping that they can win and hoping
that's enough meanwhile wei yi
he's kind of put his knight not quite in
the stable where it's stuck off the
board because it does have a retreat
square but black's knight is not on a
great circuit at all
yeah i mean if you swap the white king
and bishop around white might actually
be winning yeah which is quite funny if
you just you gotta notice these patterns
i mean uh you were talking about
instinct earlier i think that's a great
way to improve your your instinct is to
just you know open a random chess
magazine okay lots of pawns getting
swapped off here so i'm assuming this is
now and it was more of a draw but i was
just going to say open a chess magazine
look at the position and try to find the
move that the players played is is a
good way to try and prove your instinct
i think
and i suspect the game will finish very
shortly the white king is uh planning to
round up
the b pawn and the bishop will sacrifice
itself
for the last remaining blackboard and
that's it
there you go
it's coming there is no way that way ye
can avoid the draw
yeah and uh all the pawns are about to
disappear and
i think we have a result
there we go
king of bishop versus king is a draw